[Musica]
o minimo ma sto mai vuota
all
cento
ebbene sì
la sua dolce
[Musica]
così e smi
amenità
okaka non bocca
[Musica]
come me
sono a pezzi
e lui
qui
[Musica]
a many times ma sindaco
all intensità
[Musica]
poi mi vorrai how many years ma
stranamente quante orecchie deve avere
un uomo prima di sentire gli altri che
piango
su questo verso mi sono sempre fermato
cantando blowin'in the wind
credo che si fermasse bene anche lui
quando la cantava quante ore che abbiamo
quante ore che dobbiamo avere
se gli eden ci hanno dato due orecchie
diceva un filosofo è una bocca sola
forse una ragione ce l'aveva e invece
noi pensiamo che ci alleniamo per
parlare per scrivere vi assicuro che
tutti gli speaker che ascolterete qua ci
siamo impegnati e invece pensiamo che
per ascoltare basti stare li ascolto è
una parola impegnativa è però difficile
ascoltare per ascoltare bisogna
concentrarsi a impegnarsi bisogna
sollevare un po come volare bisogna
sollevarsi bisogna spostarsi bisogna
andare da un'altra parte bisogna voler
cambiare
e siccome ascolto è una parola di sette
lettere come vedete da questo dai
puntini forse intuite che sto per
costruirci su un gioco di parole da un
linguista questo ci si può aspettare
sette suggerimenti che voglio proporvi
saranno scanditi dalle sette lettere di
questa parola per ascoltare il modo
efficace il primo a ascolta per
ascoltare e non per rispondere o per
giudicare beh pensate all'evento bob
dylan so che iniziare con bobina non è
la cosa più popolare di questi tempi
però qualcuno gliel'ha chiesto qual è la
sua posizione gliel'ha chiesto perché si
è comportato così
no siamo stati dopo i primi momenti di
latitanza prontissimi ad attaccarci un
etichetta proprio prepotente arrogante
chi si crede di essere
poi quando ha dichiarato no grazie e
scusate molto gentili
quel giorno lì ho da fare se sono
scatenate ma insomma ho da fare si dice
quando ti invitano per per il raduno dei
compagni di liceo ho da fare non si fa
chissà magari e lui si sente non lo so è
però non glielo abbiamo chiesto
e questo è quello che facciamo di solito
noi ascoltiamo pochissimo ascoltiamo
quel tanto che serve per metterci un
etichetta credo che lo stiate facendo
anche voi lo facciamo tutti volevano
investito anche per cento la chitarrina
asta parlata milanese polo ero capace
anch'io e qualunque cosa accada qui
velocissimi siamo nel metterci un
etichetta oppure ascoltiamo quel tanto
che basta che ci serve per rispondere
pensate una riunione di lavoro
parla uno parla l'altra per tac certo
punto mi parte l'embolo e io comincia a
preparare la mia risposta non ascolto
più gli altri a una conferenza quando
dicono poi ci sarà spazio per le domande
e io preparo la mia domanda in un
ascolto quello che dico ascoltare per
ascoltare e basta è il primo allenamento
che vi propongo poi c'è la sda sconto
ascoltiamo solo parole
beh c'è un sacco di altri elementi che
ci possono aiutare nell'ascolto sapete
sono tre i canali attraverso i quali noi
esprimiamo quello che abbiamo dentro le
parole congiuntivi i verbi nomi e sugli
aggettivi e poi abbiamo tutta la parte
fonetica pro sodica dicono quelli che
parlano i suoni il timbro della voce il
tono della voce se hai un timbro come
gassman come proietti come lilli gruber
6 avvantaggiato se ce l'hai come la
iervolino sei un po più in difficoltà
mario giordano e con quella voce libera
impegnarsi tanto però se io ho una voce
alla gassman e comincia a parlare con
questo tono vado avanti 10 minuti e
dormi anche con lui quindi in certi
punti bisogna andare molto vicino anche
punti molto giù certi momenti bisogna
accelerare con citare l'attenzione altri
momenti le persone rallenta in certi
momenti si fanno
nelle pause pensate che buco nello
stomaco quando sei davanti a un medico
che sfoglia la tua analisi angel
comincia a parte to un'ansia se avete
una persona che amate anche nell'era
interpersonali potreste fare un
esperimento sull'effetto di una pausa
potreste prenderla a bruciapelo senza
avviso bisogna scuotere di dimmi la
verità di melania mi e questo sì ecco
quando uscirà la parola che ti aspettavi
che cosa ti ha girato dentro e poi c'è
tutta la parte fisica o l'abito il
sorriso la la postura pensate i gesti se
io mi disse se adesso abbiamo una grande
opportunità cioè vi dico la parola
grande con le mani in faccia un gesto
piccolo quanto via città sono felice di
essere qui oggi alte non ci credete
se vi dico sono molto felice è che
potete crederci allora il secondo
allenamento ascoltiamo le parole e
ascoltiamo un sacco di altri elementi
che stanno intorno
l'aci certe parole è opportuno ascoltare
in particolare certe parole quali sono
abbiamo un infinità di parole nelle
nostre lingue 185 mila sono circa le
parole dei dizionari quelli alti così
465.000 il dizionario più ricco sono
sette volumi o se non ricordo bene
perché contiene queste più le parole dei
cosiddetti this nazionali italiani
speciali per il settore
il medico il giuridico l'assicurativo il
bancario lo sportivo
fatemi parlare gli informatici di palo
droppa lo becca palo da un tool to lo
download i print ilo flag i lori
applaudirlo for words tra di loro si
parlano perfetto è si capiscono
pensate che disastro avviene se io dico
una parola in un mio ds e tu la legge
nel tuo disse premio io intendevo la
coppa prigione lo sportivo tu intendevi
il pagamento della polizza positivo e
negativo
qui dentro vogliono dire quello che
dicono no comandato il test molto
positivo
sarete contenti in fondo a un analisi
medica non sono sfumature è il contrario
settimana prossima se voteremo voteremo
sì per dire sì e no per dire no
ed è un'eccezione perché di solito
referendum fanno il contrario
allora di questa infinita mola di parole
con un sacco di ambiguità noi circa ne
abbiamo 250 che sono chiamate le nostre
ott le parole che ci scaldano il cuore e
di queste una cinquantina sono chiamate
le nostre keyword se le parole chiave
quelle che il cuore ce lo aprono o cielo
chiudono
se c'è qualcuno di voi che si chiama
alessandro come me quando ci presentiamo
vi sarà capitato alessandro anch'io però
la prima roba che ti arriva in testa sei
tu o come i tuoi figli come le persone
che ami se riuscisse a vedere alcune
teste canute tra di voi saprei che per
esempio la parola fornero ad alcuni di
voi magari cambia la temperatura allora
quanto è utile quando io ascolto una
persona a riconoscere le parole che
danno energia vigore amore salute onore
libertà
le parole sulle quali le persone mettono
enfasi riconosciamo le e trattiamo le
con la massima cura o o è una parola che
genera un bivio mangi questo o mangi
quello preferisci starei qui o andare
altrove congiunzione disgiuntiva siamo
sicuri che quando ascoltiamo un racconto
di qualcuno ascoltiamo il racconto
oppure lo ascoltiamo nella nostra
percezione dei nostri pregiudizi nella
nostra rappresentazione
mettete qui una cosa più un'altra e
un'altra ancora qui c'è i fatti della
vita
la partita di calcio una guerra un atto
d'amore
qui c'è la mia percezione e qui c'è
quello che vada in giro a dire c'è gente
che con fondi sul tema c'è gente che con
fondi queste tre piani c'è gente che
pensa di pensare sempre il vero di avere
la verità in tasca gente che pensa di
dire il vero c'è gente che pensa di dire
sempre ciò che pensa conoscete molta
gente che dice io non penso la lingua
dico tutto quello che penso
se sei cosi vattene su un'isola del
pacifico chi butta via le chiavi e non
far danni in giro cioè quando avevi sei
mesi potevi dire tutto ciò che pensavi
adesso ti hanno pensato i bambini di sei
mesi quando vengono finita la patta
vengono presi messi sulla spalla
coccolati e la mamma gli dà delle
bacchette a ciò che il bambino manifesti
al mondo la sua felicità e quando la
manifesta la mamma lo premia il torino
quando ci ha 14 anni quel cristo li
dovrebbe aver filtrato no che tra ciò
che si sente ciò che si dice si
manifesta allora distinguiamo la realtà
dal pensiero sulla realtà dalla
rappresentazione linguistica e
mettiamoci le nostre tar è lesta per
logica strutture logiche cos'è l'analisi
logica e l'analisi delle sequenze non
delle parole dentro una frase un giorno
in un convento un novizio chiese al suo
priore padre posso fumare mentre prego e
fu rimproverato castigato come il
peggiore dei peccatori
un minuto dopo un altro novizio chiesa
lo stesso priore padre posso pregare
mentre fumo e fu lodato per la sua
devozione la storiella vi sembra anche
stupidina ma fumare mentre prego e
pregare mentre fumo è la stessa roba
nella stessa cosa quello che genera la
differenza sta nella percezione
dell'altro
ci sono persone che prima di raccontarti
una cosa devono a farti le premesse
esempio perché dicono guardi devo dire
una cosa però prima ti devo fare una
promessa o la promessa di mila cosa o
viceversa
ma quelli che bontà e la sbattono sul
muso e tu avevi bisogno delle cause che
hanno generato quell'effetto se un
medico dice un paziente signor mario
giovanni quello che è la situazione
piuttosto grave ma per fortuna l'abbiamo
presa in tempo e siamo ottimisti per il
futuro oppure dice signor mario per
fortuna l'abbia presa in tempo e siamo
ottimisti ma la situazione è piuttosto
grave è uno no è la stessa realtà sì
quello che cambia la percezione allora
le sequenze logiche causa ed effetto
effetto causa passato presente futuro
futuro passato presente sono il
significato che le persone danno a ciò
che hanno da dire
ascoltiamo le senza giudicare
riconosciamo le e apprezziamo
penultimo allenamento ascolta anche tra
le parole la testa per trae anche per
trans che vuol dire oltre tra e oltre le
parole
per esempio in questo sono fantastiche
le mamme le mamme sono cintura nera di
leggere tra le parole come data a scuola
oggi ecco la mamma comincia a scavare
nel senso che ti ha segato nel senso che
l'ha esaltata nel senso che non c'era il
prof cioè però le mamme sono mosse
dall'amore nel fare un'indagine lo fanno
anche gli investigatori sistemi i
poliziotti con sistemi un po più i
commerciati b lo fanno gli psicoanalisti
andare tra e sotto le parole per
ascoltare aiutando la persona che parla
magari facendo delle buone domande per
esempio sono spaventato da cosa sei
spaventato da quando sei spaventato come
sei spaventato in che modo
dove hai sentito che eri spaventato la
domanda perché non sempre una buona
domanda
non voglio venir fuori con voi perché
perché no la domanda perché molto spesso
genera una chiusura invece girandole
intorno si riesce andare sotto dentro
intorno alle parole far venir fuori
qualcosa di più significativo è l'ultimo
punto la o di ascolto vi richiede una
cosa un po strana vi chiedo di mettervi
in fondo a questa frase leggerla al
contrario come si fa di solito quando si
atterra in un volo si pensa volgare
quanta strada fatta da dove sono partito
leggete dal contrario once upon a time
c'era una volta gli et e info avvia una
veste tutte le favole quasi tutte le
favole in sé con questa formula che la
formula è la narrazione delle narrazioni
non le favole sono le storie per
eccellenza e la gente racconta storie
ascoltiamo i racconti delle persone che
non sono solo i fatti sono il valore che
le persone attribuiscono quel fatto
se io dovessi raccontarvi qualcosa su
questa penna vi direi che è di plastica
che c'è un po di metallo però vi direi
se vi raccontassi che cosa rappresenta
per me dal fatto che io la tenga qui e
non nel mio astuccio un'idea può venir
lì c è il valore e la persona che me
l'ha regalata e il significato che
attribuisco le persone non fanno l'amore
o la guerra per i fatti fanno l'amore o
la guerra per il significato che
attribuiscono ai fatti e quindi ci sono
persone che ti raccontano la visita
cantato dal medico o la il film il ted
che hanno visto le persone che ti
raccontano le storie che vorranno vivere
in futuro ai have a dream martin luther
king ha raccontato sotto forma di sogno
cioè una storia passata un obiettivo sa
per muoversi tra passato e futuro è il
valore delle narrazioni ascoltiamo con
amore i racconti delle persone perché è
veramente il maggior atto d'amore che
noi possiamo rivolgere una persona
ascoltare le loro storie tese come ho la
sensazione che mi abbiate ascoltato
lasciate che vi risponda grazie
[Applauso]